Generating HTML from within
Python isn't all that fun.
I am sure you're getting pretty tired
of having to create these strings we've
called output over and over and over.
This can get pretty cumbersome as our
application gets more and more complex.
Because of that,
Flask configures a template engine for
you to store your HTML code.
To render a template you can
use this cleverly named method
called render_template.
All you have to do is provide
the name of the template and
the variables you want to pass to the
template engine as keyword arguments.
Here I will render a template for
my menu items page.
Flask will look for my templates
in a folder named templates.
So I'll make a directory called
templates in the same folder as my
Flask application, and from within
it I'll create an HTML document and
call it menu.html.
But what about when we need to get
information from our database or
Python code into our HTML?
This retrieval of data
is called HTML escaping.
Templates in Flask are already
pre-configured to handle escape code.
That is, the code that we
are retrieving from our application and
database, and putting it into our html.
With HTML escaping we have
access to python variables and
functions, and can even get the results
added directly into our HTML code.